this week the vegas golden knights are  back in action  the fourth season will be shorter of  course the nhl is only playing 56  regular season games because of the late  start and the pandemic  vegas is only also going to play the  seven other teams in their division here  on the west coast  they'll play two games at a time on each  road trip and at home as well  and right now fans aren't allowed at  t-mobile  strange to say but there is an energy in  that building even  uh you know without the fans and and  obviously there's much more of an energy  with them  so the first game thursday night they're  starting the season against anaheim  those two teams will play  saturday night as well